how many alien civilizations are out
there when you when you looked up at the
stars with your mom
and you were counting them
what's your mom think about a number of
alien civilizations i actually don't
know
i would imagine she would take the
viewpoint of you know she's pretty
humble and she knows how many you know
there's a huge number of
potential spawn sites out there so she
would spawn say spawn sites yeah
you know this is our sport
you have spawn sites in polytopia we
spawned on earth you know it's
hmm yeah spawn sights
why does that feel weird to say
spawn
because it makes me feel like it's
um
there's only one source of life and it's
spawning in different locations that's
why the word spawn
because like it feels like life that
originated on earth
really originated here right it is it is
a unique to this particular
yeah i mean but i don't in my mind it
doesn't exclude
you know the completely different forms
of life and different biochemical
soups
can't also spawn but
i guess it implies that there's some
spark that is
yeah which i kind of like the idea of it
yeah and then i i get to think about
respawning
like after it dies like what happens if
life on earth ends is it
is it gonna restart again probably not
it depends maybe earth is depends on the
type of you know what what's the thing
that kills it it kills it off right if
it's a paper clip maximizer not that you
know for the for the example but you
know some kind of very
self-replicating
you know high on the capabilities very
low on the wisdom type thing so whether
that's you know grey goo green goo
you know like nano bots or
just a shitty misaligned ai that thinks
it needs to turn everything into paper
clips um
you know if it's something like that
then it's going to be very hard for life
you know complex life because by
definition you know a paperclip
maximizer is the ultimate instantiation
of molecule deeply low complexity over
optimization on a single thing
sacrificing everything else turning the
whole world into although something
tells me like if we actually take a
paper clip maximizer it destroys
everything it's a really dumb system
that just and envelops the whole of
earth
and diverse
i didn't i didn't know that part but
okay great that's what it is it becomes
a multi-planetary paperclip maximizer
well it just it just propagates i mean
it it depends whether it figures out how
to jump the vacuum gap
um
but
again i mean this is all silly because
it's a hypothetical thought experiment
which i think doesn't actually have much
practical application to the ai safety
problem but it's just a fun thing to
play around with but yeah if by
definition it is maximally intelligent
which means it is maximally good at
navigating the environment around it in
order to achieve its goal
but
extremely bad at choosing goals in the
first place so again we're talking this
orthogonality thing right it's very low
on wisdom but very high on capability um
then it will figure out how to jump the
vacuum gap between planets and stars and
so on and thus just turn every atom it
gets its hands on into paperclips yeah
uh by the way for for people who which
is maximum virality by the way that's
what virality is
but does not mean that morality is
necessarily all about maximizing paper
clips in that case it is so for people
who don't know this just a thought
experiment example of an ai system
that's very
that has a goal and is willing to do
anything to accomplish that goal
including destroying all life on earth
and all human life and all of
consciousness in the universe you know
for the goal of producing a maximum
number of paper clips
okay oh or whatever it's optimization
function was that it was set up but
don't you think could be making
recreating lexus maybe it'll tile the
universe in likes
go on i like this idea now i'm scared
that's better that's that's more
interesting than paper clips that could
be infinitely optimal if i were to say
so it's still a bad thing because it's
permanently capping yeah what the
universe could ever be it's like that's
that's its end or achieving the optimal
that the universe could ever achieve but
that's up to different people have
different perspectives uh but don't you
think within the paperclip world
that would emerge
just like in the zeros and ones that
make up a computer that would emerge
beautiful complexities
like it it won't
suppress
you know as you scale to multiple
planets and throughout they'll they'll
emerge these little worlds
that uh on top of the fabric of
maximizing paper clips there will be
that that would emerge like little
societies of
of uh
paperclip well then we're not with them
we're not describing a paperclip
maximizer anymore because by the like if
you think of what a paperclip is it is
literally just a piece of bent iron yes
right
so if it's
maximizing that throughout the universe
it's taking every atom it gets its hand
on into somehow turning it into iron or
steel
and then bending it into that shape and
then done and on
by definition like paper clips there is
no there is no way for well okay so
you're saying that paper clips somehow
will just emerge and create
through gravity or something no no no no
because there's there's a dynamic
element of the whole system it's not
just
it's creating those paper clips and the
act of creating there's going to be a
process and that process will have a
dance to it because it's not like
sequential thing there's a whole complex
three-dimensional system of paper clips
uh you know like you know people like
string theory right it's supposed to be
strings that are interacting in
fascinating ways i'm sure paperclips are
very string like they can be interacting
very interesting ways as you scale
exponentially through three-dimensional
i mean i'm sure
the paperclip maximizer has to come up
with the theory of everything it has to
create like wormholes
right it has to break uh like it has to
understand quantum mechanics i i love
you i love your optimism this is where
i'd say this we're going into the realm
of pathological optimism whereby it's
um i'm sure there will be uh
i i i think there's an intelligence that
emerges from that system so you're
saying that basically intelligence is
inherent in the fabric of reality and
will find a way kind of like goldblum
says life will find a way you think life
will find a way even out of this
perfectly homogeneous dead soup it's not
perfectly homogeneous it has to it's
perfectly maximal in the production i
don't know why people keep thinking it's
harmony it's it maximizes the number of
paper clips that's the only thing it's
not trying to be homogeneous it's trying
to
true
maximize paper clips so you're saying
you're saying that because it because
you know kind of like in the big bang or
you know it seems like you know things
there were clusters there was more stuff
here than there that was enough of the
patronicity that kick-started the
evolutionary process the little
weirdness that will make it even out of
yeah city emerges
interesting okay well so how does that
line up then with the the whole heat
death of the universe right because
that's that's another sort of
instantiation of this it's like
everything becomes so far apart and so
cold and so
perfectly
mixed that it's like
homogeneous grayness
do you think that even out of that
homogeneous grayness where there's no
you know negative
entropy that you know there's no uh free
energy
that we understand
even from that
new
yeah the paperclip maximizer or any
other intelligence systems will figure
out ways to travel to other universes to
create big bangs within those universes
or through black holes to create whole
other worlds to break
the what we consider are the limitations
of physics
the paperclip maximizer will find a way
if a way exists and we should be humbled
to realize that we've been yeah but
because it just wants to make more paper
clips yeah so it's going to go into
those universes and turn them into paper
lips yeah but we
humans not humans but complex systems
exist on top of that we're not
interfering with it
the this complexity emerges
from the simple base state the simple
basis whether it's yeah whether it's
you know plank lengths or paper clips is
the base unit yeah i you you can think
of like the universe as a paperclip
maximizer because it's doing some dumb
stuff like physics seems to be pretty
dumb
it has
like i don't know if you can summarize
it yeah yeah the the laws are fairly
basic and yet out of them amazing
complexity emerges and its goals seem to
be pretty basic and dumb
if you can summarize as goals i mean i
don't i don't know what's a nice way
maybe
um
maybe laws of thermodynamics could be i
don't know if you can assign goals to
physics but if you formulate in the
science in the sense of goals it's very
similar to
pay-per-click maximizing in in the
dumbness of the goals but the
the pockets of complexity has emerged is
where beauty emerges that's where life
emerges that's where intelligence that's
where humans emerge and i i think we're
being very down on this whole paper clip
maximize the thing now the reason we
hate it i think yeah because what you're
saying is that you
think that the force of emergence itself
is another like unwritten one not
unwritten but like another baked in law
of the of of reality yeah and and you're
trusting that emergence will find a way
to even out of seemingly the most
molecule awful out you know plain
outcome emergence will still find a way
i love that as a philosophy i think it's
very nice i would
wield it carefully because
there's
large error bars on on that and the
certainty of that yeah um and while we
build the paper clip maximizer and find
out classic yeah molok is doing
cartwheels man yeah yeah but the thing
is it will destroy humans in the process
which is the thing which is the reason
we really don't like it we we seem to be
really holding on to this whole human
civilization thing
would you would that make you said if
ai systems that are beautiful that are
conscious that are interesting and
complex and intelligent
ultimately lead to the death of humans
that make you sad if humans led to the
death of humans sorry
like if they would supersede humans oh
if some ai yeah ai would uh would end
humans i mean that's that's that's the
reason why i'm like in some ways i'm
less emotionally concerned about ai risk
than say bio you know biorisk because at
least with ai there's a chance you know
if if we're in this hypothetical where
it wipes out humans but it does it for
some like
higher purpose it needs our atoms to an
energy to do something at least now
there's the universe is going on to do
something interesting
um whereas if it wipes everything you
know bio like just kills everything on
earth and that's it and there's no more
you know earth cannot spawn anything
more meaningful in the in the few
hundred million years it has less left
because it doesn't have much time left
um
then
uh
yeah i i don't know
so one of my favorite books i've ever
read is uh nova scene
by james lovelock who sadly just died um
he wrote it when he was like 99.
he died aged 102 so it's a fairly new
book
um and he sort of talks about that that
he thinks it's you know
so building off this gaia theory where
like earth is like living
some form of intelligence itself and
that this is the next like step right is
this this whatever this new intelligence
that is maybe silicon based as opposed
to carbon-based goes on to do um and
it's a really sort of in some ways an
optimistic but really fatalistic book um
i don't know if i fully subscribe to it
but it's a beautiful piece to read
anyway
so am i sad by that idea i think so yes
and actually yeah this is the reason why
i'm sad by the idea because if something
is truly brilliant and wise and smart
and truly super intelligent
it should be able to figure out
abundance
so if it figures out abundance it
shouldn't need to kill us off it should
be able to find a way for us it should
be there's plenty the universe is huge
there should be plenty of space for it
to go out
and do all the things it wants to do and
like give us a little pocket where we
can continue doing our things and we can
continue to do things and so on um and
again if it's so supremely wise it
shouldn't even be worried about the game
theoretic considerations that by leaving
us alive will then go and create another
like super intelligent agent that it
then has to compete against because it
should be omni-wise and smart enough to
not have to concern itself with that
unless unless it deems humans to be kind
of [ __ ]
like uh like
the humans are a source of none of a
lose-lose kind of dynamics
well
yes and no
we're not molecules that's why i think
it's important to say but maybe humans
are the source of molecule
no i mean i think
game theory is the source of molok and
you know because molok exists in in
non-human systems as well it happens
within like agents within a game in
terms of like you know
uh it applies to agents but it like it
can apply to you know
a species that's on an island
of animals you know rats out competing
the ones that like
massively consume all the resources are
the ones that are going to win out over
the more like chill
socialized ones and so you know creates
this malthusian trap like moloch exists
in little pockets in nature as well well
so it's not a strictly human i wonder if
it's actually a result the consequences
of the invention of predator and prey
dynamics
maybe it needs to ai will have to kill
off
every organism
that you're talking about killing off
competition
not competition but just um
like the way uh it's like uh
like the weeds or whatever in in a
beautiful flower garden the parasites
yeah
on on the whole system now of course it
will it will it won't do that completely
it'll put them in a zoo like we do with
parasites it'll ring fence yeah and
there'll be somebody doing a phd on like
they'll prod humans with a stick and see
what they do
[Laughter]
but uh i mean in terms of letting us run
wild
outside of the uh
you know geographically constraint
region that might be
uh that it might
decide to against that no i think
there's obviously the capacity for
beauty and kindness and
non-uh
non-moloch behavior amidst humans so i'm
pretty sure ai will preserve us
uh let me
uh you i don't know if you answered the
the aliens question you you i didn't you
had a good conversation with toby uh
toby yes about various sides of the
universe i think did he say no i'm
forgetting but i think he said it's a
good chance we're alone so the the
classic you know fermi paradox question
is
um
there's so many spawn points and
yet
you know it didn't take us that long to
go from harnessing fire to
sending out radio signals into space
so surely
given the vastness of space we should be
and you know even if only a tiny
fraction of those create
life and other civilizations too we
should be the universe should be very
noisy there should be evidence of dyson
spheres or whatever you know like at
least radio signals and so on but
seemingly things are very silent out
there um now of course it depends on who
you speak to some people say that
they're getting signals all the time and
so on and like i don't want to make an
epistemic statement on that but um
it seems like there's a lot of silence
and so that raises this paradox
and then
they
uh the you know the drake equation
so the drake equation is like uh
basically just a simple thing of like
trying to estimate the number of
possible uh civilizations within the
galaxy by multiplying the number of uh
stars created per year by the number of
stars that have planets planets that are
habitable blah blah so all these like
different factors um and then you plug
in numbers into that and you you know
depending on like the range of you know
your lower bound and your upper bound
point point estimates that you put in
you get out a number at the end for the
number of civilizations
but what toby and his crew did um
differently was toby this is a
researcher at the future of humanity
institute uh
they instead of
they realize that it's like basically a
statistical quirk that if you put in
point sources even if you think you're
putting in conservative point sources
because
on some of these variables the
the uncertainty is so large it spans
like maybe even like a couple of hundred
orders of magnitude
um
by putting in point sources it's always
going to lead to um overestimates
um and so they
by putting stuff on a log scale actually
they did it on like a log log scale on
some of them um and then like ran the
simulation across the whole
um bucket of uncertainty across all
those orders of magnitude when you do
that
then actually the number comes out much
much smaller and that's the more
statistically rigorous you know
mathematically correct way of doing the
calculation it's still a lot of hand
waving as science goes it's like
definitely
you know just waving i don't know what
an analogy is but it's hand wavy um and
uh anyway when they did this and then
they did a bayesian update on it as well
to like factor in the fact that there is
no evidence that we're picking up
because you know no evidence is actually
a form of evidence right um and
the long and short of it comes out that
the
we're roughly around 70 to be the only
uh
intelligent civilization in our galaxy
thus far and around 50 50 in the entire
observable universe which sounds so
crazily counter-intuitive but their math
is
legit
well yeah the math around this
particular equation which the equation
is ridiculous on many levels but uh the
the the the powerful thing about the
equation is there's the different things
different components that can be
estimated
and the error bars on which can be
reduced with science
and enhanced throughout since the
equation came out the error bars have
been coming out on different aspects
yeah that's right aspects and so that it
almost kind of says
uh what like this gives you a mission to
reduce the error bars on these estimates
now over a period of time and once you
do you can better and better understand
like in the process of redoing the error
bars you'll get to understand actually
what is the right way to find out where
the aliens are how many of them there
are and all those kinds of things so i
don't
think it's good to use that for an
estimation i think you do have to think
from like
more like from first principles just
looking at what life is on earth
like and trying to understand the very
physics-based biologic
chemistry biology based question of what
is life
maybe computation based what the [ __ ] is
this thing right and that like how
difficult is it to create this thing
right it's it's one way to say like how
many plants like this are out there all
that kind of stuff but
it feels like from our very limited
knowledge perspective the right ways
to think how how does what is this thing
and how does it originate from
from very simple non-life things how
does complex
life like things emerge
from from a rock
to a bacteria
protein and these like weird systems
that
encode information and pass information
from self-replicate and then also select
each other and mutate in interesting
ways such that they can adapt and evolve
and build increasingly more complex
systems right well it's a form of
information processing yeah right
right
whereas information transfer
but then also an energy processing which
then results in
i've i guess information processing
maybe i'm getting buggered well so it's
doing some modification and yeah the
input is some energy right it's able to
extract yeah
extract resources uh from its
environment in order to achieve a goal
but the goal doesn't seem to be clear
right
the goal is well the goal is to make
more of itself
yeah but in a way that uh
increases i mean i don't know if
evolution
is a fundamental
law of the universe but it seems to want
to
replicate itself in a way that maximizes
the chance of its survival
individual agents within yeah an
ecosystem do yes yes evolution itself
doesn't give a [ __ ] right it's a very i
don't care it's just like
oh you optimize it well at least it's
it's certainly um
yeah it doesn't care about the the
welfare of the individual agents within
it but it does seem to i don't know i
think it's i think the mistake is that
we're anthropomorphizing it's to even
try to you know give
evolution a mindset
um because it is there's a really great
post by eliezer uh yudkowski on um
uh less wrong which is um
an alien god
and he talks about like the mistake we
make when we try and like put on
think through things from an
evolutionary perspective as though like
giving evolution like some kind of
agency and what it wants
um yeah worth reading but
yeah i i would like to say
that having interacted with a lot of
really smart people that say that
anthropomorphization is a mistake i
would like to say that saying that
anthropomorphization is a mistake is a
mistake i think there's a lot of power
in anthropomorphization
if i can only say that word correctly
one time i i i think that's actually a
really powerful way to reason through
things and i think people especially
people on robotics seem to run away from
it as fast as possible
and uh i i just can you give an example
of like how it helps in robotics
oh in uh
that
our world is a world of humans
and to see robots as fundamentally just
tools
runs away from the fact that
we live in a world of a dynamic world of
humans that like these all these game
theory systems we've we've talked about
that a robot that ever has to interact
with humans and i don't mean like
intimate friendship interaction i mean
in a factory setting where it has to
deal with the uncertainty of humans all
that kind of stuff you have to
acknowledge that the robot's behavior
has an effect on the human
just as much as the human has an effect
on the robot and there's a dance there
and you have to realize that this entity
when a human sees a robot
this is obvious in a physical
manifestation of a robot they feel a
certain way they have a fear they have
uncertainty they um
they they have their own personal life
projections we have pets and dogs and
the thing looks like a dog they have
their own memories of what a dog is like
they have certain feelings and that's
going to be useful in a safety setting
safety critical setting which is one of
the most trivial settings for a robot in
terms of how to avoid
any kind of dangerous situations and a
robot should really con consider that in
navigating its environment and we humans
are right to reason about how a robot
should consider navigating its
environment through anthropomorphization
i i i also think our brains are designed
to think in in
humans um
human terms like game theory
i think is um
is is best applied in the space of human
decisions
and so
uh right you're dealing i mean with
things like ai ais they are
you know we can somewhat
like i don't think it's
the reason i i say anthropomorphization
we need to be careful with is because
there is a danger of
overly applying overly wrongly assuming
that that this
artificial intelligence is going to
operate in any similar way to us because
it is
operating on a fundamentally different
substrate like even
dogs or even mice or whatever in some
ways like
anthropomorphizing them is less of a
mistake i think than an ai even though
it's an ai we built and so on because at
least we know that they're running from
the same substrate and they've and
they've also evolved from the same out
of the same evolutionary process
you know they followed this evolution of
like needing to compete for resources
and
needing to find a mate and that kind of
stuff whereas
an ai that has just popped into an
existence somewhere on a like a cloud
server let's say you know or whatever
however it runs and whatever whether i
don't know whether they have an internal
experience i don't think they
necessarily do in fact i don't think
they do but
the point is is that to try and
apply any kind of modeling of like see
thinking through problems and decisions
in the same way that we do
has to be done extremely carefully
because they are
like
they're so alien
their method of whatever their form of
thinking is it's just so different
because they've never had to evolve
you know in the same way
yeah i was beautifully but i was just
playing devil's advocate i do think in
certain contexts anthropomorphization is
not going to hurt you yes engineers run
away from it too fast
you're right
you